[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui j'ai invité une yvelinoise
qui va nous parler de son livre je
réussis ma détox sucre elle s'appelle
bérengère philippon baie rose r bonjour
bonjour merci d'être sur le plateau de
tv 78 c'est d'avoir invité à écouter
c'est un grand plaisir et puis j'ai
beaucoup de deux d'intérêt de curiosité
pour ce livre déjà vous même alors vous
vous êtes dans le milieu médical quel
est votre travail
alors je suis pas du tout dans le milieu
médical mais je m'intéresse beaucoup à
tout ce qui est nutritionniste adorent
cuisiner d'accord par contre que mon
travail n'a rien à voir avec avec la
cuisine lorsque je suis responsable
marketing et communication chez hatier
donc de travail dans les livres de
colère voilà - et vous avez une
formation scientifique ou si je crois
oui tout à fait moi j'ai toujours été
plus science donc j'ai fait une
formation donc à la fac de versailles
en gros en chimie et sur les arômes
alimentaires donc a déjà à la base
c'était alimentation et de la roma voilà
c'est ça c'est bien
alors qu'est ce qui vous est pris ce
livre pourquoi bastien four tire
d'ailleurs j'oublie laisser aux
aujourd'hui voilà tout fret mois chez
larousse voilà alors j'ai décidé de
décrire ce livre tout simplement parce
que j'ai eu un peu un déclic il ya deux
ans voilà j'ai pas mal d'amis autour de
moi qui ont eu des petits soucis de
santé
moi même j'ai fait du diabète
gestationnel diabète gestationnel c'est
que tony est enceinte
voilà pendant ma deuxième grossesse
d'accord donc voilà je sais que tout ce
qui est sucré il faut que je fasse
attention parce que j'ai toujours été un
vrai bec sucré et donc à 40 ans voilà un
peu le moment où on a on a des
interrogations se remet en cause et donc
je me suis dit ouh là faut peut-être que
je fasse attention à moi à ma santé
ouais et donc j'ai décidé de diminuer de
sucre et en fait ça s'est transformé une
grande aventure
j'ai eu énormément de bien fait et je me
suis beaucoup informé parce que voilà
comme j'imagine j'écoutais toujours ce
petit côté scientifique j'aime bien
savoir un sweep irrationnelle et
cartésien j'imagine donc alors vous avez
donc décidé d'arrêter entre guillemets
de diminuer le sucre
alors comment comment on fait comment
c'est d'abord comment se présente ce
livre je crois qu'il est en deux parties
oui d'accord la première vous évoquez
votre parcours vous évoquez les
bienfaits de la détox voilà parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y en a énormément en
fait on s'imagine pas qu'il y en a
autant
bon alors allez-y faites moi la liste je
suis presque williams à plat les
principaux alors on va dire et puis
effectivement il y en a bien un qui
apparaissent petit à petit on voit pas
tout d'un coup oui c'est pas non plus
voilà quoi persévérer we made you que
c'est surtout premiers mois qui est
difficile
parce que c'est vraiment le mois où il
faut un faut arrêter ce vrai voilà c'est
ça c'est vraiment ce sevrage qui est un
peu plus difficile mais après ça va
après c'est beaucoup plus simple alors
donnez moi les bénéfices déjà s'il vous
plaît alors le les premiers bénéfices
c'est déjà plus taquine et je n'avais
pas beaucoup des quarante ans elle a pas
beaucoup mais voilà j'en avais toujours
un petit peu et ça a commencé à
disparaître à tina oui donc ça peut
marcher pour des ados qui eux ont
l'argana ce jour là je pense que ça peut
vraiment améliorer ça va peut-être pas
de vous enlever bien sûr moi ça a été
dur et senans d'accord après il ya aussi
un effet sur le transit parce qu'on
mange plus de fibres d'accord il ya un
effet aussi sur la qualité de la peau je
trouve et ce qui m'a le plus
impressionné personnellement c'est la
fin de ses pulsions sucré à la fin du
repas parce que vous en aviez beaucoup
oui à chaque fois la fin du repas il
fallait que je prends pas du tout
chocolat au lait ou des petits gâteaux
après un repas normal vous aviez une
envie de sucre oreilles après avoir pris
un dessert enfin un dessert yauch et on
installe mollahs et après il fallait que
vous alliez prendre un truc encore plus
sucré mais voilà il fallait que c'était
là la foule comme ça j'espérais que
c'est vraiment ça qui m'a le plus
impressionné de le fait de se dire tiens
j'ai pu cette envie de sucre très forte
et arrive à la fin du raid pas
renouvelables et avait fait un
franchement c'est faux lui faut le vivre
pour le croire mais elle reste que le
sucre est une drogue
ça fait un peu cette impression là
effectivement plus on en consomme plus
on va avoir envie en fait d'en prendre
on alimente le voilà et de corps et âme
en bas il a toujours besoin parce que
c'est ça devient une habitude et les
jamais rassasié ben disons qu'il va être
rassasié pendant une heure ou deux et
après ben vous allez avoir encore ce
manque de sucre en fait il va apparaître
au niveau du sens plus on lui redonne
plus l'on veut quoi là oui mais quand je
comprends et en plus quand on en a quand
on en prend trop way le corps en fait le
transforme en mauvais gras et donc ça ça
en fait tu fixes et qui fait les caisses
qu'il a prise de poids voilà c'est ça
bon d'accord c'est pour ça que dans mon
lit en fait j'ai voulu
avant de commencer à proposer des
recettes expliquées en fait expliquer
tout ça tout ça fait que j'ai fait
d'accord
et alors du coup donc les bénéfices ok
on a compris
alors comment comment est-ce qu'on s'y
prend puisque c'est une comme si c'était
une drogue pour ce pour se sevrer c'est
pas du jour au lendemain ou ou du jour
en main comment vous avez fait alors moi
le le premier mois j'ai été enfin je
fais plusieurs phases dont le tout
premier mois où vraiment cette phase de
sevrage
j'essaie d'arrêter au minimum enfin
vraiment en fin d'année raté au maximum
et c'est vrai que comme c'était un petit
peu difficile j'ai essayé de trouver des
compensations voilà donc je bâtis au
chocolat noir à 90 pour sa peau c'est
pas facile au début mais pitié mais j'ai
essayé de prendre si pas mal de
noisettes d'amandes de noix parce que ça
ça cale et à et ça permet en fait
d'enlever ses pulsions sucre est
d'accord donc à l'appel du chocolat au
lait après le déjeuner ou dîner une noix
un peu plus le web
voilà et puis à un ou deux petits 4
chocolat noir très fort en voilà et
c'est vrai que ça calme un peu et puis
c'était une façon c'est un petit truc
que j'avais trouvée pour d'accord et
donc visiblement ça s'est fait
progressivement et au bout d'un mois ses
envies de ses pulsions en fait ont
disparu voilà enfin on vraiment
nettement diminué ok beaucoup plus
facile d'arrêter de mieux manger
alors après il faut faire attention
c'est que dans le set détox sucre
attention danger damman au dessert mais
il faut aussi faire attention aux autres
sucres voilà ce que les sucres entre
guillemets qu'on appelle lent
c'est quand même du sucre le sucre est
partout quasi maintenant tout ce qui est
du site oui j'ose donc le bal les
céréales les
légumineuses
les farines savait pas dire il faut
qu'ils ont mangé c'est au contraire
enfin votre corps a besoin d'un minimum
ça fait tous voilà donc c'est juste
qu'il y en a certains qui sont à
privilégier par rapport à d'autres donc
ça vous nous expliquer voilà voilà
vous répondez aussi alors vous avez un
compte instagram vous avez 48 1000
followers
oui déjà en combien de temps peu moins
d'un an et demi bah oui extras comme
quoi ça parle à tout le monde
oui j'ai pas mal qu'est ce qu'on peut
constater sur les questions d par
rapport aux questions des gens j'ai pas
mal de questions sur voilà comment faire
évidemment donc c'est bon ça qui me dit
bon ben là au moins ce qui doit
permettre d'y répondre oui vous senti un
vrai besoin
voilà et puis comment faire aussi au
quotidien quand on est précis quand on
n'a pas le temps prat voilà quand on a
une famille n'est peut-être pas à fond
aussi sur ce type d'alimentation
voilà j'essaie de répondre aussi dans
mon livre à savoir comment faire quand
on a invité aussi été donnés les trucs
concrets pratique pour le quotidien
voilà c'est ça d'accord et vous avez mis
toute votre famille en des toques du
coup pas on va dire que la su bah il ya
pas mal de choses qui passent très bien
alors vous me donnez moi des petits
exemples balles et les desserts faits
maison
des gâteaux pour le goûter vous
remplacez le goût sucré par quoi alors
on
j'utilise plus effectivement de sucre
blanc ouais ni de sucre complet non plus
parce qu'au final ça quand même le même
impact
mais j'utilise d'autres types de sucre
en com
certains miels comme le miel d'acacia ou
le sirop d'agavé
ou alors aussi le sucre de bouleau des
choses comme ça ça peut être utilisée
par contre en pâtisserie nous voilà dans
les desserts là il faut faire quand même
attention c'est évidemment il faut pas
se dire fin g de sucre je remplace par
100 g de sirop d'agavé ça marche pas
comme ça
d'accord des buts c'est quand même de
limiter la quantité de sucre même si
c'est du entre guillemets faux sucre
donc voilà j'ai nettement diminué et en
fait on se rend compte que en diminuant
la quantité de sucre on a pas moins de
saveur il faut vraiment trouver
l'équilibré avec un mal de tête pas eu
des ratés fin voilà est en fait comment
être qu'on s'habitue à manger moins
sucré c'est comme quand on y prend du
sud note son café le jour où on a quand
on arrête de mettre du sud dans ton café
15 jours par malheur on boit un café
sucré on a juste envie de cracher quoi
la wii a pas tout à fait enfin et c'est
vrai que des habitués voilà si encore
une fois c'était un petit chacun voilà
il y avait un dessert je me suis bon je
vous passe rue je vais pas d'hier voilà
je vais quand même en prendre
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment vraiment fait de
respirer et c'est vrai que c'est enfin
c'est fou on n'a pas l'impression que le
palais comme ça que plus d habitude
c'est un peu comme celle oui oui tout à
fait ouais ouais d'accord donc alors ça
c'est la première partie du livre est
donc vous détailler vraiment votre votre
cheminement étape par étape vos
questionnements et la résolution des
problèmes que vous avez rencontré donc
ça c'est très pratique et concret et
comment faire ses courses etc voilà et
et la dernière partie ce sont des
recettes
voilà parce que tant qu'à faire autant
réaction à l'action est exactement là où
faire des recettes quand même assez
facile voilà joue à la personne qui
feinte la mère de famille quoi en fait
voilà qui a pas toujours le temps qui le
soir faire des choses quand même rapide
tout en mangeant sainement et voilà
j'essaie proposait surtout des choses
des recettes qui sont difficiles à faire
quand on veut manger index glycémique
bas par exemple par exemple des quiches
voilà évidemment si on achète une patate
à retraite dans le commerce mais c'est
ce que j'ai vécu dix ans formé
industrialisés c'est bourré de sucre
entre guillemets mais disons que c'est
pas des farines qui conviennent après on
peut en trouver un
il ya des pins par exemple ils peuvent
aller donc heureusement on peut quand
même mais c'est vrai que voilà bah faut
quand même fou nez et les bonnes
lunettes n'est vos yeux regarder les
étiquettes etc
voilà c'est ça d'ailleurs j'ai une
petite explication c'est recommandé de
lire des étiquettes aussi pour essayer
de mettre des choses très pratique
ouais vous êtes mis à notre place voilà
et puis je ne savais pas que j'étais le
travail oui merci
et alors juste donc des recettes donc
des choses compliquées ou avoué comme
vous dites une qui gère une mousse au
chocolat on peut encore en feu où ça
n'existe plus dans votre monde ici
puisque la mousse au chocolat et l'excès
c'est vous oui ben je n'ai pas mis
dedans parce que c'est vrai que je peux
pas tout mettre une recette de crème au
chocolat par exemple - et la mousse à
l'heure du coup qu'est ce qu'on fait
mais la mousse au chocolat mois des
noirs déjà très large chocolat très noir
et au final des jeux normands pour moi
la vraie recette c'est des oeufs et du
chocolat il n'y a pas de sucre à la base
ben voilà donc après il ya du sucre dans
le chocolat donc bien sûr mais au moins
cela limite la quantité
jean lapointe bon et au niveau du la
prise de poids de la perte de poids ça
aide aussi
personnellement moi ça m'a aidé alors je
n'ai pas beaucoup de poids à perdre mais
c'est vrai que dernièrement la dernière
année j'avais plus 3 kg d'un coup alors
que ça m'était jamais arrivé donc je me
suis dit ouh là si c'est ça chaque année
la rage et voilà et lalanne ont au
contraire franchement de fait de manger
un index simbao - moins de sucre mais on
a vraiment j'ai un petit peu plus de 40
ans gardent de la gourmandise et il faut
pas avoir peur parce que franchement
voilà moi j'ai réussi même à perdre 5
kilos et j'ai d'autres personnes seront
compte instagram qui est également aussi
perdu pas mal de poids
génial ben écoutez ça donne juste envie
de dévorer ce livre à igé bas et puis de
vous suivre
un grand merci à bérangère philippon
donc on est chez larousse
et ça vient de sortir à très bientôt
merci
[Musique]